美聯儲可以說是這個星球上對金融市場影響力最大的機構政策出債問題就導致了20世紀最嚴重的全球經濟大蕭條一刺激就帶來了美國股市十多年的大牛市稍微監管不嚴呢又招來了多次的金融海嘯這12個人開開會動動嘴皮子的決策就能影響全球經濟
而就是這麼重要的機構，它竟然還有股東，每年還會分紅。What?就美聯儲這個話題，說實在的，小林還是有點發言權的。畢竟之前在華爾街工作的時候，其實很大一部分就是在關注美聯儲的決策，還有那幫老教授腦子裡都是怎麼想的。所以咱今天不光聊美聯儲，我也想藉著美國央行來跟大家一起聊一聊中央銀行的運作機制，它在制定貨幣政策的時候的一些權衡取捨，還有關於美聯儲我的一些小思考。
美聯儲全稱叫做聯邦儲備系統Federal Reserve System簡稱FED注意這個FED它沒有S當然S呢FEDS就變成FBI的黑話是槽子大家千萬可別搞混了
美聯儲是美國的中央銀行，掌管美國的貨幣政策，包括印錢，制定短期的利率政策等等。你要是仔細看美元紙幣上，都會寫一個大大的Federal Reserve Note,就是美聯儲兌換券，這個東西就是錢。大家現在可能會覺得，央行社國家就有，它是個非常常見的政府部門的標配了。但我跟你說，美國還真不是這樣。就從1776年建國到現在大概250年的時間裡，有超過一半的時間，它壓根就沒有中央銀行。
因為美國人嘛大家從骨子裡就不相信中央政府就不相信中央集權那套東西就連印錢這種事他也不想建什麼中央銀行中間確實有兩次因為大家有打仗確實沒錢了就合夥建立了一個臨時性的中央銀行也就是美國第一銀行和美國第二銀行然後這兩個所謂的中央銀行都是在幫助各州渡過難關之後成立了20年就可以關了你可能就納悶了要沒有中央銀行的話誰來印錢呢說出來你可能都不信就是誰都能印
19世紀的時候，很多私人銀行都可以發行自己的票據，基本上就等同於錢。美國當時主打自由競爭嘛，你看，都已經能自由到這個份上了。當然這不是說你隨便拿張小綠紙，然後畫個小紙，寫個100就拿出去畫了，那肯定不是這樣的。錢確實誰都能印，但是真正能流通的錢你必須得有抵押物，就比如說金，銀，或者是美國聯邦政府的國債。後來到19世紀末的時候，銀行接連出現了幾次系統性危機。就大家一聽見風水草動，就立馬到銀行去擠兌換錢。
最嚴重的一回是在1907年美國政府都不得不求了私人銀行家JP Morgan出馬才利用了他個人的威望和資金幫市場渡過了難關經過這麼一通折騰大家終於意識到說不行這個自由競爭實在是太可怕了咱還是得有個中央銀行至少在這些商業銀行被擠兌的時候得有個央行兜底於是聯邦政府開始起草了美聯儲法案並在1913年正式建立了美聯儲
美聯儲的制度設計其實是非常精妙的。之前美國一直為什麼沒有中央銀行？是因為民眾對中央政府不信任，不願意讓政府說了算。但是你要建立一個機構完全脫離政府的控制，政府肯定也不樂意。所以在討論美聯儲運作機制的時候，政府和私人銀行家經過了一番激烈的博弈。撕扯了三四年之後，才找到了一個大家都相對接受的平衡點，來看看他們是怎麼解決的。
你聽美聯儲的全稱它叫聯邦儲備系統不叫聯邦儲備銀行所以它不是個銀行是由12個地區儲備銀行組成的系統這12個儲備銀行都有各自的管轄區負責管理這個區域裡邊所有的商業銀行每個儲備銀行都是由這個地區裡邊上千家成員銀行控股
也就是說美聯儲它其實是一傢俬人銀行控股的機構。聽到這大家可能會有些疑問，咱一會兒再細說。這些巨銀行確實有一些在行政事務上的自主權，但是但凡涉及到一些關鍵的貨幣決策，比如假期印錢這種，還是在中央有一個集中的決策層，叫做聯邦公開市場委員會，就是FOMC。注意了，這個FOMC別看就四個字母，它是非常非常非常重要。
這裡邊總共有12個人這12羅漢就成了真正制定美國所有重要貨幣政策的組織也是美聯儲決策漩渦的核心你想全球有60%的外匯儲備是美元而美元發多少利率是多少全都是由這12個人開會說了算可能就幾個人一邊吃著盒飯一邊討論咱要不加個C全球幾千億資金立刻回籠美國就這麼牛
這十二個人裡邊有七個叫執行委員，包括了其中一個是美聯儲主席，現在是鮑威爾。這個主席的位置是四年一屆，可以連任。其他六個成員呢，任期是14年。就這七個執行委員，包括主席在內，全都是由總統任命的。參議院通過就可以直接上任。那這十二羅漢裡剩下那五個席位呢，是由地方聯儲的主席輪值擔任。就大家每年可以輪著做。
其中這五個席位裡因為紐約聯儲太重要了所以紐約聯儲的主席常年霸佔一個席位剩的那四個席位是由剩下的11個地方聯儲換著做大概是這麼個意思這樣就組成了FOMC的十二人超強天團
這12個人每年要聚在一起開8次會也就是每一兩個月就要開一次會就是咱們常說的Fed Meeting商討的都是最最最最重要的貨幣政策開完會就會發一個叫Statement會議記錄比如說美聯儲要不要加息加多少個基點都是會議之後公佈而這個也是全球金融市場絕對的焦點
就是因為這個FOMC實在是太重要了就我之前上班的時候我們都會列出來這12個人每個人是什麼風格然後關注他們的言論一般龍統來說我們一般會把這些人分成鴿派跟鷹派大家要是不知道怎麼記怕記穿了鴿派就放鴿子嘛就放就放鬆降息呀刺激呀多一點錢這種鷹派呢相反縮進
你像之前幾屆的主席波丹克那就是典型的鴿派之後的耶倫也是偏鴿派現在的鮑威爾就相對比較中立而那十二個人裡邊不是有四個是在地方聯儲主席裡邊輪換嗎所以你就不光得關注現在這四個人是什麼風格你還甚至得關注下面要上來的這四個人是什麼風格我記得特別清楚當時有一哥們叫Cash Carey16年當上了地方聯儲的主席他就是個超級無敵大鴿派以至於他當時一被選上主席整個股市都跟著漲你就可見這十二個人的影響力有多大
FOMC再往下這十二個地方儲備銀行每個都有九個董事會成員其中六個是由這個地方的商業銀行推舉出來三個由執行委員推舉算是政府的人大家先別著急我說完之後要講一個美聯儲非常重要的特性所以先忍一忍這整個執行委員FOMC一幫聯儲和成員銀行構成了美聯儲一個簡化版的框架這個框架體現出來的一個核心思想是什麼呢就是治好
政府和私人銀行之間的制衡就這裡面每一層董事會都既有銀行的人又有政府的人最底層全都是商業銀行控股集中決策層FOMC又大部分是政府委派的執行委員可後來慢慢的就FOMC這七個執行委員雖然他們是政府的人選出來的算是有政府背景可是政府也不一定能管得了他們因為一旦任命之後政府其實就很難罷免了他需要國會三分之二以上的投票通過才行你比如說18年底的時候正好是加息週期政府肯定不喜歡加息
要知道那時候美聯儲主席鮑威爾那可是特朗普剛剛親自任命上臺的結果轉頭特朗普就開始罵了說我覺得對美國來說美聯儲的問題比中國還要嚴重他們犯了一個巨大的錯誤因為我有直覺我的直覺告訴我的比任何人的腦子都要多
當然偷老虎的說話咱給他打折挺但是你多多少少可以感覺至少從表面上來看美國政府對美聯儲的控制力其實很弱即使總統親自捧上來的人他也不一定按照自己意思來鮑威爾自己在採訪的時候都說了
他搞了這麼一套複雜的運作機制，要達到一個什麼目的呢？就是為了保證美聯儲的獨立性和他決策的公正性。因為市場清楚，美聯儲清楚，包括美國政府也清楚，美聯儲的基石其實在信任。因為手上權力是大，可是這個是基於市場對你的信任。全球市場對你越信任，就越多人用你的貨幣，那你的影響力就越大。這是個正向的機率。
而美聯儲中立機制就是為了維持這份信任。就不是說美國政府讓我幹什麼我就幹什麼。這個信任帶來的長期收益是要遠遠超過幾次貨幣政策給政府帶來的那種小小的短期收益。說到這兒給大家插一個歷史小故事。其實二戰剛結束之後就全球的市場對美聯儲還並沒有那麼信任。但在1979年美聯儲上任了一位主席叫保羅沃克。他贏得了市場的心。也可以說是美聯儲主席裡面一個傳奇級的人物。
他的任期其實說起來挺倒楣的經歷了兩次石油危機當時美國的通脹居高不下他為了壓住通貨膨脹當時是頂著全社會的壓力直接把利率幹到20%以上加息當然可以抑制通貨膨脹但是也會抑制經濟的火力美國當時的失業率甚至超過了10%不光是政府的政客對奧羅沃克這個極端政策表示不滿就連民眾甚至都會給他祭死亡威脅政府都得派特勤局去保護他的安全就連任命他的總統塔特當了一屆就被弄下臺了
就是沒有人能阻止得了沃克加西的決心。結果美國經歷了短暫的陣痛之後，通脹真的就被摁下來了，開啟了美國經濟之後長達20年的高速發展。
此役之後沃克也是一戰風神向全世界市場證明瞭說美聯儲可以穩住美元美聯儲不會受美國政客們的擺佈讓大家可以安心的持有美元順利的幫美國從金本位制的時代過渡到了浮動匯率的時代其實也就是美元為王的時代而美聯儲自然就成了全球金融體系當中權力最大的機構反正總之就因為它連動著全球的資本市場
所以美聯儲它的一舉一動都是全球關注的焦點。現在很多投資平臺都可以幫助我們隨時去追蹤美聯儲的動向。比如說我們的老朋友以戰時交易平臺MUMU就有這個財經利率可以訂閱聯邦基金利率、CPI等等這些關鍵的經濟數據，發布的時候就能收到提醒。他還能直接就看到歷史數據和預期的對比，方便投資者可以快速洞察市場信號，做出決策。
而且它有中、月、英三語，對華人就非常友好。最近不是高息環境嗎？姆姆也給大家準備了現金收益計劃的大禮。就你帳戶裡隨存隨取的現金，也可以獲得安全的高收益了。美國5.1%,加坡5.8%,香港最高9.7%,澳洲最高6.8%。就這樣不交易也可以有收益，還是蠻有競爭力的。
另外各個地區的新用戶開戶還可以零股零現金每股最高有15股具體的信息我就放在置頂評論了公募一個賬戶就能投資每股加股新股澳股港股A股通基金期權期貨債券它一個非常重要的特色就是費率低對投資者來說便宜比如說每股ETF期權都是零用金
而且一些專業的，就本來需要訂閱的功能，它都是免費提供。像實時行情，物質對比，還有六種高級條件訂單。不用盯盤，就可以自動止損，或者把福音落袋為安。可以更高效地執行自己的投資策略和控制風險。最近，木木在加拿大地區也上線了，最高有1500加幣的現金獎勵。各個地區的小夥伴都可以在置頂評論領取木木的福利。好，我們說回美聯儲啊。
剛才我們說到了美聯儲的架構和決策的獨立性。有一些善於思考的朋友們到這可能就疑問了，咱不是說美聯儲是由所有的成員銀行共同持股的嗎？那你理應就應該為股東的利益最大化考慮，你怎麼能說他獨立呢？咱倆在這說說股份制這個事。
首先美聯儲確實是給這些商業銀行股東們回報，而且回報率非常可觀，高達6%。但實際上這6%聽著雖然很爽，但這些股東股本金是非常少的。你要看他的財報就知道，他2022年給美國所有的商業銀行總共才分了12億美元。就他私人持股這個屬性，現在象徵意義已經遠遠大於實際作用，而且美聯儲的股票是完全不能流通的。
所以就有點像一個商業銀行要入會的一個會員押金的作用。這個商業銀行它不會指著美聯儲賺錢，美聯儲也不會為股東的利益服務。所以有些人說美聯儲是個私人企業，這個法理上還OK,你聽個段子也可以，但本質上你肯定不能把它理解成一個私人企業。不過我跟你說，雖然它不給股東分那麼多錢，但美聯儲它實際上是非常賺錢的。而這個錢你知道都給了誰嗎？美國政府。這個其實是很多人沒意識到的。
首先咱得知道美聯儲存的利潤是怎麼來的你不能說這個錢是我印的就算我的利潤就算我這肯定不行那印出來的錢其實相當於什麼相當於一個零息貸款那我可以拿這個錢出去放貸或者拿這個錢出去買各種投資品貸款之後的利息或者投資品帶來的回報這部分都可以寄到我的營收下面而這些所有的利潤除去那些象徵性的分紅以外都會上交給美國財政部
我還特意根據他的財報算了一下他這十年的數據。平均來講，美聯儲每年會給美國財政部貢獻900億美元。最近不是加息嗎？因為他手裡大部分是一些固收債券，都大跌。所以22年他賺的有點少，直上交了590億美元。美聯儲把利潤給出去了，其實這個行為能保證他決策的公正性。就是他的貨幣政策不會受我賺多賺少的影響。政府可就爽了。雖說理論上美聯儲跟政府是完全獨立的，
那你就靠這麼個部門每年就能收進來小一千億是吧你看看即使對於美國政府來說也是一筆不小的油水而且我跟你說你就結合著美聯儲量化寬鬆這條線走一下美國政府借國債不管利率多少這頭有一部分是美聯儲印錢給買下來之後呢美聯儲的收益又還到給了財政部你看看這繞了一圈不就相當於美國政府零息去找美聯儲貸款了嗎
好，咱剛才說的那麼一打通，非常精彩。但咱其實主要說的是美聯儲的獨立性。那美聯儲作為一個獨立的中央銀行，它的目標是什麼？它又有什麼武器來達到這個目標呢？
首先它的目標非常簡單最重要的目標就兩穩定的物價和最大就業不過這兩個目標經常是會衝突的你想刺激就業那你可能就需要寬鬆的貨幣政策就會導致通貨膨脹物價上漲比如說當時沃克為了按住通脹加息導致失業率的上升這兩個之間怎麼平衡這個是需要美聯儲去拿捏的
當然現在普遍的經濟學認為這個物價穩定是更重要的這個咱們在通脹那期詳細拆解過那美聯儲都有哪些貨幣政策呢？其實它在早期這個武器庫是非常豐富的這個利率那個貸款控制各種地方但隨著市場一點點成熟它的武器庫也開始化繁為簡主要它就控制一個東西就是利率
而且不是所有的利率是聯邦基金利率Fed Funds Rate銀行之間拆借一晚上的利率我們平時說美聯儲加息降息其實指的也都是這個利率我覺得大部分朋友其實知道這就差不多了它具體怎麼去調節那個一天的利率我們就不細說了你看它實際上是有一些工具歸根結底都是在控制我們剛剛說的那個一天的聯邦基金利率
這短期利率其實就決定了市場當中錢的流通速度，也就實際控制了市場裡邊貨幣的多少。其他所有的利率，像你的存款利率、房貸利率、國債利率等等，全都是由市場供需決定的，就美聯儲它沒法直接控制。當然，雖然它沒法直接控制，其實那些所有的利率跟美聯儲能控制的那個一天的聯邦基金利率相關性是非常高的。這個我們在利率那期詳細的講過。
美聯儲這套體系進化到上個世紀90年代格雷斯潘是美聯儲主席的時候可以說是所向披靡成功地頂住了幾次股市崩盤和亞洲金融危機的衝擊市場覺得它已經非常接近完美了這就好像什麼就好像19世紀的時候那時候的物理學就覺得自己已經瞭解宇宙的真諦了除了幾朵烏雲以外就沒有什麼自己不知道的誰知道20世紀量子力學和相對論打開了物理學潘多拉的魔盒中央銀行的潘多拉的魔盒則晚了一個世紀在21世紀被打開了
2008年雷曼兄弟倒閉金融海嘯席捲全球為了刺激經濟美聯儲把利率從5.25迅速幹到了半個世紀以來的最低位幾乎為零但是面對這百年一遇的動盪你光降利率完全不夠市場的信心還幾乎在冰點於是美聯儲又開始了下一次升級他就想起在前幾年日本央行那個操作量化寬鬆就是QE
就我不光只控制這個短期利率了我可以專門印錢去市場上買長期的債券這樣可以壓低長期利率那全社會不就可以以一個更低的成本去融資了嗎這招其實是非常有風險的就美聯儲它也不知道自己搞量化寬鬆之後結果會是怎麼樣因為其實日本也就只是小範圍的幹過兩次之外就沒有人在搞過這個事了FOMC的成員事後都承認說這其實是一次實驗一次堵上美國經濟的實驗
但也沒辦法為了避免美國再次陷入80年前的類似的大蕭條美聯儲主席伯南克決定嘗試量化寬鬆他要把1.75萬億的債券這個相當於市場上所有流通債券的四分之一在一年多的時間裡全都給買下來了此招一出市場立刻震動10年期的國債利率兩天降了一百多個幾點由於利率下降債券的投資收益率下降大量的資金就湧向了收益率更高的資產主要就是股市股票在QE期間高格猛進金融市場是一片黃紅
而資產價格的大漲通過財富效應也確實帶動了實體經濟財富效應就是股票一漲大家就覺得自己的財富增加了就會增加消費總需求增加從而帶動整個社會的信心其實中國前些年房地產的上漲也通過財富效應很大程度上刺激了中國經濟的發展
指住了上升的勢頭開始穩步下降那美聯儲一看這招挺管用接著又來了第二波和第三波的QE三輪下來效果還不錯以免美國陷入了衰退看起來美聯儲好像又一次成功地化解了危機可是就在他準備把這些零食性的政策慢慢推出來的時候問題出現了市場出現了耀武以來
2013年5月，美聯儲主席伯南克公開說，考慮要減少量化寬鬆，就是Taper。注意，這說的都不是要開始賣手裡的債券，只是說買的少一點，慢一點。而且說的是考慮，還沒有開始減少，市場立刻就開始慌了，債市恐慌性暴跌。10年期的國債利率在半年之內漲了100多個級別。
看到市場如此激烈的反應博南克立馬出來圓場說不好意思不緊縮了不緊縮了我之前說的就當我放了個屁屁這才緩和了緊繃的市場情緒這個鬧劇就是著名的taper tantrum縮表恐慌事件它意味著什麼就是說之前美聯儲靠QE這一劑猛藥讓市場快速恢復市場就太舒服了太爽了產生了藥物依賴結果現在美聯儲想減量市場立刻開始撒破大棍
而我跟你說美聯儲這波QE它最大的作用都並不是刺激了實體經濟而是締造了一波股市的神話注意這是一個幽默的諷刺
這個其實就是美聯儲採取貨幣政策的時候一個非常尷尬的地方就在經濟不景氣的時候甭管我是降低利率印錢買債券這些金融機構它其實是不願意把收入錢放貸出去的而是更願意去投資在美國呢主要就買股票那上市公司呢正常利率降了它可以低成本融資了吧但它其實也更傾向於去回購自己的股票就說白了還是買股票所以裡外裡這麼一看美聯儲不管是什麼貨幣政策最後大部分的資本還是流向了股市
雖說美聯儲的目標是穩定物價和降低失業率你可沒聽說要讓股市上漲但結果就是美聯儲一刺激股市就狂狂漲這個可不光是美聯儲其實全球的央行都面臨類似的問題就它只能決定我印多少錢花多少錢但它其實沒法決定這個錢花在哪這就好比說什麼就美聯儲它掌控了一個灌溉系統就你可能想讓它這個水去澆比如稻田農場但是呢它能做的就只能是把上游那個水閥給打開打放水水往哪流它確實沒有辦法去控制
可能確實有一小部分流到了這個稻田農場，也就是實體經濟。可實際上呢，大部分水，全都流到了邊上的蓄水壺裡邊。這個蓄水壺，可能是股市，可能是房地產，也可能是海外資產。
所以我們大師總說，炒股最重要的是看什麼？是看財報嗎？不是，是看美聯儲。華爾街上流傳著一個經典名句叫Don't fight the Fed,別跟美聯儲對著幹。美聯儲已經成了股市的財神爺了。雖說美聯儲很獨立，但華爾街還是會通過各種方式給美聯儲施壓。就是你這QE不能停，你這藥不能停，這樣才有助於美國的經濟。就在美聯儲好不容易安撫下來市場，咱這個寬鬆是不是有點過分了？開始要加息縮表的時候，疫情來了。
得 熟悉的流程再來一遍利率歸零 量化寬鬆只不過這回美聯儲真的已經清車出路了上回伯南克要搞這個事的時候還研究了好幾個月這回鮑威爾一個週末就給搞定了而且這回是人類史上最大規模的QE不光買國債不光買MBS連公司債都買對待所有人都居家經濟幾乎停擺的時代股市卻又迎來了一波狂歡你說高效不高效
僅僅一年後由於美聯儲海量的量化寬鬆再加上美國政府5萬億的財政刺激美聯儲最害怕的終極大冷魔終於開始覺醒通貨膨脹美聯儲可以有100個理由繼續給經濟注水餵藥但是一旦這個怪獸覺醒那就什麼也別說了假吸
一年之內加了500多個基點你要知道全世界大部分的貨幣和大部分的經濟體全都掛著美元的直接引發了全球大面積的經濟動盪不光是2022年全球資產大跌美國自己也在2023年僅僅兩個月之內就迎來了歷史上的第二第三第四大的銀行倒閉事件
這次銀行業的動盪，美聯儲是脫不了幹系的，它也正在醞釀著又一次的升級。美國這長達十幾年的過度寬鬆，又緊接著抽風式的緊縮，到底還有什麼副作用，還有哪些潛在的危機呢？我們現在還不得而知。
其實你看這30多年美聯儲的政策就會有一個感覺就是當經濟一片大好的時候它就會放得太開等市場玩崩了呢美聯儲又為了保證市場的穩定不得不出來救市這其實並不是美聯儲的本意它最開始希望的其實就是自由的市場競爭效率最大化但萬一出事了呢我就出來救一下我來保個底可這樣時間一長就會演變出什麼呢就華爾街好你們可以隨便玩玩崩了反正美聯儲都個底它這麼一次次救市就甚至已經培養出了華爾街這種感覺產生了一種本能反應second nature
其實吧往深了說我覺得不光是華爾街跟美聯儲它有這層矛盾就在金融體系的每一個層面上都有這個問題這個遊戲機制就讓這個玩家都有一個兜底的選項你想啊金融公司玩崩了有美聯儲有美國政府兜底一般公司玩崩了呢大不了破產嘛也可以兜底比如說一個基金經理哪怕再虧虧大不了就是被開除嘛他自己本身的錢也不會受影響而一旦賺錢了呢那就是尚不封頂全歸自己你看啊金融它本身其實是一個槓桿的遊戲就是在風險收益之間的一個權衡取捨
但是因為有這個兜底的遊戲機制，它就導致了風險和收益其實是不對等的。這好比什麼？就比如說你玩一個扔硬幣的遊戲，正面你贏錢，輸了呢，背面你虧同樣的錢。這很公平合理是吧？
可是現在如果我告訴你你還是正面贏錢背面虧錢但這個虧錢你是有封頂的你最多就虧一百萬這個懲罰就上限了那你想這時候你利益最大化的策略是什麼那你就盡可能賭上個最大比如說我賭一個億那贏了我拿一個億輸了我大不了虧一百萬這樣我的預期收益就一下子從零變到了將近五千萬
所以你看這個虧損封頂的遊戲規則就會鼓勵這個市場裡邊的所有玩家去從事風險更高的活動你從事這個活動的風險越高它的預期收益其實也是更高的
其實像金融市場裡的基金經理、上市公司、華爾街銀行，他們都非常清楚這套遊戲規則。你要是仔細想想，其實不光是金融行業，整個市場上的很多經濟活動也都遵循這個原理。那美聯儲肯定不希望因為自己可以兜底，就鼓勵這些金融機構去不斷的放大槓桿。所以他慢慢就意識到，其實事前的監管，比事後的救市更重要。
所以他在08年金融危機之後是極大的增加了他的監管力度不過這個力度顯然好像還不太夠你看今年這銀行劈里啪啦的倒閉估計這個美聯儲又開始醞釀下一輪的監管該怎麼升級了
其實關於美聯儲我還有點想聊的，就是我覺得他做的很好的一個地方，就是他保持了和市場中間這個充分的溝通的透明度。這一點其實任何市場從業者應該都深有感觸，也讓大家對美聯儲多了很多的respect。就是他會特別詳盡的向你公開他到底是怎麼想，每個決策背後的依據，甚至包括這12個人具體是怎麼投票的，這12個人具體又都是怎麼想的。啊對，這個非常有用，叫做Dot Plot。
每次FOMC會議之後都會公佈這個點點圖告訴你這12個人每個人他覺得未來的利率大概可能感覺是個什麼樣的他全都給你公佈出來這個點點圖有的時候甚至比利率政策還重要比如說你要加息是加25個幾點還是50個幾點其實市場上早就預測個大八九不離十了但是這FOMC裡面每個成員他對未來預期是怎麼樣的這個波動就比較大了所以也會成為市場關注的一個核心
其實美聯儲還真的公佈了大量的經濟研究資料在他們網站上。雖然網站設計有點醜，但確實藏了不少寶藏。像經濟數據，他們的理論研究，科普，甚至是論文等等。這裡面在業界比較有名的有一本叫《Beige Book》，直譯過來叫做米色的書。國內一般不都叫白皮書，但可能美聯儲才會更喜歡米色。這本書每隔一段時間就會更新一次。
包括了12個地方聯儲做的一些經濟研究，還有當地的經濟狀況，應該算是從業者必看的。雖然你感覺美聯儲最後的決定可能都極其簡單，就是加息或者不加息，加多少個基點，你可能感覺這可能是全世界最簡單的工作了。可是他們就是通過各種的研究報告甚至演講，來告訴你說，他這個是經過了縝密的決策之後才決定這個水龍頭這次要開多大的。他不是就是隨便一拗嚇唬鬧的，說到底呢，還是為了增加市場對他的信任。
這期我除了跟大家科普了一下美聯儲的機制啊、歷史啊、目標啊等等，也深入地探討了一下它的一些問題，還有底層的遊戲邏輯。其實各國央行也都遵循著和美聯儲大概類似的邏輯。這期視頻說實話可能不是那麼好理解，我也參達了不少亂七八糟的信息還有我自己的想法，說實在的我都覺得還挺好的捨不得刪。所以你能看到這兒，我覺得你真是挺棒的。如果你要是把這期結合了之前的利率，通過膨脹、融匯貫通一下，我覺得肯定會讓大家
對宏觀經濟、宏觀政策，包括央行的決策理解非常有幫助。